j'ai une question sur l'allemagne vous
avez rappelé et l'allemagne fait partie
du job plutôt que 8 des réserves de
charbon
et pourtant au niveau européen ils sont
assez moteur sur les réductions des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre alors
est ce que c'est d'être un orateur sur
la réduction où il ya des gens qui aura
discours moteur sur la réduction je peux
me tromper notre âge fini ma question
quand même qu'est ce que c'est des
bisounours des escrocs c'est les deux à
la fois on va on va se livrer à une
petite analyse secteur par secteur dans
le domaine de la performance thermique
des bâtiments
les allemands ou une politique plus
volontariste que la nôtre dans le
domaine de la performance des moyens de
transport ils ont une politique beaucoup
plus laxiste que la nôtre puisque les
industriels qui font le plus pression à
bruxelles pour que ne baisse pas par la
réglementation rapidement les
consommation maximale admissible des
véhicules neufs qu'on vend ses les
constructeurs allemands dans le domaine
de l'énergie
là ils sont en train de faire alors ils
ont fait des rayons j'en sais rien mais
si on s'intéresse stricte strictement au
co2 ils sont en train de faire ce qu'il
faut pour augmenter les émissions de co2
et non pas les baisser
donc quand vous dites enfin quand plus
exactement on a un sentiment diffus
essentiellement tirés de l'admiration
ouverte proférées par des écologistes
français pour leurs homologues allemands
qui ont réussi à faire fermer des
centrales
vous avez l'impression que c'est un pays
très en pointe en fait quand vous
regardez le truc dans le détail ça se
discute beaucoup plus et enfin si vous
dites je vais m'intéresser qu'aux
résultats
donc je me fous des discours ce qui
m'intéresse c'est le résultat le
résultat c'est que en termes d'émissions
nationale les allemands sont à dix
tonnes de co2 par personne et par an les
français à 6 voilà donc après ça c'est
le fait vous avez trois manières de dire
oui mais je m'en fous là dérivés et
compte plus que la valeur absolue et
puis dans tels secteurs ça compte plus
que dans telle autre
voilà donc par contre l'idée simple que
je n'accepte pas c'est ils sont
vachement plus écolo cno tchad
je pense que c'est pas une bonne manière
ils sont globalement plus hostiles au
nucléaire ça c'est absolument certain
tous les tous les sondages le montrent
est-ce qu'ils ont plus écolo que nous ça
dépend comment vous définissez écolo
ils sont
ça dépend des critères encore pire ça
dépend de critères
si vous considérez encore une fois que
la question dépendance à l'énergie
importée plus changement climatique
induit est le premier truc dont il faut
se préoccuper
alors je pense que la france est plus
écolo que l'allemagne
si vous considérez que le premier truc
dont il faut se préoccuper c'est un
risque d'accident de centrales
nucléaires alors ils sont plus écolo que
nous si vous considérez que le premier
truc dont il faut se préoccuper c'est le
nombre d'éoliennes dans un pays
indépendamment des émissions de co2 des
importations d'hydrocarbures etc ils
sont plus écolo que nous non mais vous
comprenez vous avez une réponse par
critères après vous pouvez pas faire
l'économie d'une hiérarchisation des
critères c'est incontournable
ah bin là ils sont plus avec nous alors
moi je vous parle d'aujourd'hui
sans récession en août avec récession
qu'on aura probablement oui ils vont y
arriver nous aussi du reste